good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight once you decide that
human beings are Gods with the power to
rewrite history biology and nature the
power to shape reality itself once you
decide that there's no reason to stop at
sex changes transgenderism is certainly
fetish at the moment none of us can stop
talking about it but men magically
morphing into women is not the final
stage of anything instead it's the first
of many similar movements that are on
the way inevitably
and the few Visionaries who have grasped
this obvious truth weirdly have not been
welcomed by Blue America they have been
mocked and derided as prophets always
are
a few years ago for example a blue-eyed
blonde woman from Montana called Rachel
dozal declared that she was black
because she decided that she was black
Blackness was Rachel dozal's lived
experience
but she was not greeted as a liberator
she was almost immediately booed off the
stage and then she disappeared
and yet tellingly none of the people
yelling at Rachel dozal ever explained
why she couldn't be black why not in
this country you can change your sex but
not your race really how does that work
what species of science are we talking
about here it was not a defensible
argument
and so over time like all indefensible
arguments it will collapse someday the
New York Times will give Rachel dozal
its coveted glass ceiling award for her
courage in the face of prejudice that
will happen
but before it does we'd like to
highlight some of the early adopters of
our new Civic religion where each of us
is God of the universe with utter
dominion over nature these are the
Trailblazers the Pathfinders the Daniel
Boone's of progressive identity politics
one of them is a man called Justin
Pearson Pearson has been in the news
recently for helping to facilitate an
Insurrection at the Tennessee State
House you may have seen him
but you may not know what Justin Pearson
was like before his transition back in
2016 Justin Pearson was an Ernest young
student at Bowden
the whitest College in the whitest state
in America a place that cost 60 Grand a
year for no obvious reason
a rich kid School
here's what Justin Pearson looked like
then as he ran for president of student
government
I'm Justin J Pearson and I'm running for
president of BSG there are a few reasons
that we're running this campaign this
year one has to do with representation
how can we represent all voices in a
conversation I want to bring together
different voices dissenting voices
voices that may be more liberal or more
conservative in order that we can reach
a point of sort of the radical middle or
conversation and dialogue happens and
growth happens join the people's Pearson
campaign and let's chart ourselves to a
better future
I want to bring everyone together said
Justin Pearson in a voice that if you
closed your eyes you could easily
imagine coming from a Suburban
orthodontist Justin Pearson wasn't white
that's probably how he got into Bowdoin
in the first place but he did a
fantastic impression of it what a nice
young man as he considered the
apprenticeship program at Citibank
that was the old Justin Pearson before
his transition here he is now on the
floor of the Tennessee State House
all hope seem to be lost representatives
were thrown out of the State House
democracy seemed to be at its end
like the NRA in gun lobbyist might win
but oh that was good news for us I don't
know how long this Saturday in the state
of Tennessee might last but oh we have
good news folks we've got good news that
Sunday always comes
Justin Pearson has a dream that one day
on the Red Hills of Georgia everyone
will do exactly what he wants or else
face indictment by the Department of
Justice
Justin Pearson has changed quite
dramatically as you can see he
transitioned from a crypto white kid
into the modern incarnation of Martin
Luther King Jr himself it's remarkable
really but he's not alone in that you
see this all the time everybody in the
Democratic party wants to be Martin
Luther King at this point even Joe Biden
who during the famous March on
Washington was enjoying the many
benefits of Life as a college student in
a racially segregated State now he's MLK
they all are
but you got to ask yourself as long as
we're mimicking civil rights leaders who
died almost 60 years ago why not some
variety
you never see politicians transitioning
to say Malcolm X why is that maybe
because Malcolm X didn't talk like a
sharecropper he spoke dignified Standard
English he was running a Shakedown
racket to fleece guilty white liberals
Malcolm X had self-respect so he
despised guilty white liberals and he
said so he believed in self-improvement
he knew who the enemy was
so maybe it's not surprising Malcolm X
is not a popular transition choice in
2023 Al Sharpton by contrast is
increasingly popular especially now that
he's skinny and has a paying job
Sandy Cortez of Westchester recently
pulled off a double transition
not only did she change sex as Al
Sharpton identifies as a man but races
as well
here she is unveiling her new self in
front of Sharpton's own National Action
Network
I'm proud to be a bartender
ain't nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with working
retail folding clothes for other people
to buy
there is nothing wrong with preparing
the food that your neighbors will eat
there is nothing wrong with driving the
buses that take your family to work
ain't nothing wrong with that in other
words yo my brother sup
that's not bad for a girl who grew up in
an all-white suburb in leafy Westchester
County as the daughter of the president
of an architectural firm
but don't mention any of that that's
dead naming
these days she'd like a gin and juice
with salsa and Frijoles because Sandy
Cortez doesn't just transition once she
keeps transitioning she's a Cutting Edge
shape-shifter who collaps identities the
way Imelda Marcos did shoes
so she started Life as a privileged
white girl then became a middle-aged
black man engaged in the civil rights
movement and then in October she
transformed effortlessly into a lactanks
cartoon character watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right all right listen
listen Okay okay
I got you
you may call that fraudulent she calls
it transitioning they don't talk like
that in Westchester County but she
learned this from the very best Barack
Obama paved the way Obama grew up with
his white mother and white grandparents
from Kansas in an apartment in Honolulu
a city that has approximately zero black
people then he moved to Indonesia then
California and New York but at some
point Barack Obama decided he didn't
want to be any of the things he actually
was so he transitioned he became because
you can do this now an African-American
Baptist pastor from Chicago with deep
roots in Mississippi
here's Barack Obama post-transition in
December
even in his 70s wasn't tired I've got no
excuses I can't be tired if the men and
women
who had to endure the sting of
discrimination
the smack of billy clubs
weren't tired
if the folks who had to fight those
early fights those were the tough fights
for union rights and voting rights and
gay rights and women's rights if they
didn't get tired you can't be tired
Barack Obama is sick and tired of being
sick and tired it was the smack of the
billy clubs in Honolulu that did it it
was the fire hoses and snarling German
Shepherds at Harvard Law School at some
point Obama crossed the Edmund Pettus
Bridge of his mind and transitioned into
Ralph Abernathy except an atheist and
much thinner
but Hillary Clinton was there first she
transitioned when he didn't even know
what the word meant and in some ways
Hillary made an even longer Journey she
was identified by an obstetrician at
Birth as the daughter of an executive
from the Suburban Midwest but inside she
always knew she was very different from
that she was trapped inside a body that
wasn't hers
but it wasn't until 2007 that Hillary
Clinton finally mustered the courage to
identify as what she was all along a
politically aware gospel singer from the
segregated South here she is on the
chitlin circuit in Alabama
I don't feel no Ways Tired
are
from where
um nobody
would be easy
[Applause]
performing tonight ladies and gentlemen
at Constitution Hall
Joe Biden actually was born in a slave
state and as we mentioned for the first
nearly 30 years of his life enjoyed all
the many perks of living in a Jim Crow
City but that's not a story that
audiences are interested in hearing a
lot about at this point so Joe Biden did
what we are all now allowed to do in
modern America he erased his former
identity you saw this recently with a
trans Admiral he declared it never
happened
you can't know what happened it's a dead
name and he transitioned into something
else so Joe Biden still grew up in a
segregated state but now he was the one
at the back of the bus feeling the thump
of the billy club
The Sting of the fire hose Joe Biden is
now black watch
a senator from Florida going after
Medicare and Social Security
I tell you what I don't know where as
they said something doesn't know where
you all been hot damn boy
hot damn hot damn and at no time in his
life did Joe Biden ever support
segregated schools in Delaware contrary
to what Kamala Harris told us during the
Democratic debates last time
Kamal Harris has forgotten all about
that because it never happened and
Kamala Harris's case there's a whole
pallet of identities to choose from so
here you have someone who is the
daughter technically or was was
identified at Birth as the daughter of a
Jamaican college professor
and an Indian college professor who grew
up in Canada
in Montreal Quebec
so actually Kamal Harris can be
essentially anything she wants and two
years ago she transitioned and became a
baguette eating Beret wearing bicycle
riding French lady here she is
with us in government
we campaign with the plan
uppercase t uppercase P the plan
and then the environment is such that
we're expected to defend the plan
in France
we call it fromage and speak in broken
English
it's too bad the Ukrainian accent is so
hard to master because a lot of these
people would already have transitioned
into refugees from Kiev
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight